the Department of Homeland Security will
run out of money On February 28th unless
Congress passes a bill to fund the
agency what's the problem
the House version of the bill would
block Obama's new immigration policy
which has caused Senate Democrats to
filibuster the Department of Homeland
Security or DHS is massive created in
the wake of 9/11 it includes FEMA the
Coast Guard border patrol the Secret
Service and of course the TSA so what
happens if the DHS is shut down
out of the nearly 230,000 DHS employees
200,000 of those about 85% are still
required to show up for work they're
classified as essential meaning we need
them to keep working because they keep
us safe so even without funding our
national security is probably not at
risk but during a shutdown the people
protecting us will be working pro bono
because none of those essential workers
will get paid until Congress passes the
funding bill but the lapse in funding
will affect more than just paychecks DHS
will stop training thousands of law
enforcement officers and stop handing
out grants to local and state
governments the irony here is that even
with a DHS shutdown
the office that processes immigration
applications which is the whole cause of
the shutdown would remain open because
it's almost entirely funded by
application fees it doesn't need money
from Congress